Hogwarts Legacy is a game about how
Wizarding school is hard and being a
student of the magical Arts you might
have a few questions once you've started
it up like why is my inventory filling
up so fast and what can I do about it or
my character looks like they put on
everything in their wardrobe in the
morning is there an easy way to fix that
we're here to help you out with things
we wish we knew going into Hogwarts
Legacy
you might be tempted to rush out into
the open world to unlock all kinds of
things and you can but you should know
that the most important things are
unlocked by going to class and following
the main story like the room of
requirement spells that you'll need for
puzzles inside and outside of Hogwarts
and broom flight the story can unfold
pretty slowly and playing at a
reasonable Pace it might take you two to
three days to get to some of the game's
main mechanics so just take your time go
to class unlock spells and then when you
do run across the many puzzles in the
world you'll be equipped to handle them
on the spot if you do ditch class to
explore the open world before you get
brute light there is fast travel for
places you've already visited but you'll
have to slog it on the ground to get
there which can definitely be
inconvenient that's not to say you can't
do this and enjoy it there's a lot of
gear to find in even Quest specific
challenges to accomplish before you even
start those quests making them shorter
later on but do expect some Guff from
teachers about it don't forget die
studies yes
one thing that will quickly become clear
when you start playing Hogwarts Legacy
is that your inventory space is pretty
limited like very limited you'll have 20
total gear slots to begin with and this
is for all of your gear that might not
sound bad Until you realize that
Hogwarts Legacy is a loot heavy game
you'll quickly find yourself selling or
destroying about half of your inventory
on a regular basis but don't worry the
solution comes via the most famous
wizard of all time Merlin eventually in
the game you'll be able to unlock
Merlin's trials and by completing a
number of these you'll finish challenges
in your quest book doing that lets you
increase your inventory size by four
spaces at a time here's how to do it
first you'll need to progress far enough
in the story I don't want to get too far
into spoilers so I'll simply say that
the story Mission you need to finish
involves the restricted section of the
library this will unlock a quest in
lower Hogs field once you've finished
that you'll hear a screen which starts a
chain of events involving Nora Treadwell
if you help her out this will start the
Merlin's trials quests all the locations
will now appear on your map and you'll
be able to go and complete them for
solving these various puzzles you'll
finish a trial once you finish two of
these head your quest log into the
exploration tab this is where you'll
have to manually unlock your rewards
which in this case is more gear slots
complete more of these trials for more
gear it's basically just a gameplay loop
from here on out one thing to note is
you can't actually access this until you
get far enough into the story as we
mentioned before notably the restricted
Library Mission trust me we tried and
there are some fun missions on the same
location just not the one you're looking
for additionally in order to even do
these trails in the first place you'll
need mallow sweet leaves keep an eye out
for them well you'll get some simply for
helping Nora after you run out you can
purchase these at hogsmead for Fairly
cheap or buy the seeds at hogsmead and
plant them to keep growing sets of Fire
for free once you've opened up the room
of requirement until you do unlock
Merlin's trials and even after you'll
notice your collection of gear quickly
ramping up so here's a question every
piece of gear you find will have a
designation with it it could be well
appointed superb extraordinary or it
could even be legendary these
designations not only affect the cell
value of the gear but also quickly tell
you how many upgrade slots it has and
what the trade slot level is well a
pointed equipment can't be upgraded
while legendary equipment has a trade
slot level of three and can get three
upgrades so whether you want to keep or
toss this stuff has a lot to do with
what you want to do later in the game
particularly gear crafting at the loom
collecting and even selling this gear
still unlocks both skins and traits that
you can use later so there's really no
harm in doing it but if you want a
mid-max your gear holding on to the gold
stuff means that you can do most of the
upgrading when it becomes available this
one just depends on your play style
something to note here is that you might
not need to min max your gear if you're
playing a normal difficulty at that
level the combat is pretty manageable so
this could be more aimed at players who
want to crank up the challenge and then
you know men Max their stuff later on
at some point in the game you'll find
the quest the elf the knabsack and the
loom congratulations you've started down
the path of upgrades your ability to
upgrade gear at the loom has to do with
a few things beasts you catch and take
care of which give you materials Trace
that can be applied to your gear that
are found on loot or earned through
challenges and having high enough level
gear as we just mentioned to be able to
accept those traits if gear upgrades are
red for you get to catching beasts as
soon as possible head on over to Brook
and Peck outside of hogsmead to sell
those animals once your inventory gets
full keep in mind this is at the top of
the map and is actually really easy to
miss when you're looking at hogsmeade
then keep checking your challenges
combat section which will also award you
with new gears and traits to put on
outfits but as we said before you need
to manually unlock these by clicking on
them while the gear throughout Hogwarts
Legacy is fun and there's plenty of ways
you can play around with your fashion a
lot of it is a um something to say the
least if you want your character to look
massively overdressed that's totally
cool we're not here to judge you on your
fashion sense at the same time you might
be tempted to play the game without
looking like that but before you figure
this part out you're going to be looking
interesting because you're going to be
mixing and matching the best gear with
the best traits so there's good news
it's actually super easy to customize
your outfit and oddly missable head into
your gear menu and from here before you
go into customizing exactly which piece
of gear you're wearing you can click an
alternate button to change your
appearance from here you can change any
piece of clothing you're wearing to look
like any other piece of clothing you've
already collected this also includes
special outfits like the dark art set
from the pre-order bonuses or general
collectible outfits you found in the
game but might not have realized where
they went and fear not if you sell or
destroy pieces of clothing you found you
still have collected it and you can
still use its appearance another
important thing to note here is you can
make your outfit look like nothing so
you can still wear a hat or glasses for
stats but make them invisible
cosmetically and gain their bonuses
without having to look at them you can
also make your general clothing
invisible which will reveal that you've
been wearing long jammies this entire
time because Scotland must be pretty
cold during at the end of summer some
side quests are necessary to learn
spells that you'll need to actually
progress the game but you won't find
them on your map which can be a bit
confusing you'll have to check the quest
menu to see exactly what's needed of you
and what your reward will be for example
Professor hitcat has multiple
assignments for you and you'll gain a
spell reward for completing these so if
you're stuck in Camp agreso story
forward because you need a spell it's
probably in your quest lists
there's a very good chance that you get
the option to spend Talent points before
you really know what your style is it's
okay to wait until later to spend them
some of us on staff went all in on Dark
Arts but there are a few other standout
abilities to consider while you're
figuring out what kind of witch or
wizard you want to be under core the
Swift Talent not only gives you a much
better Dodge but it can also save you
time when traversing long dungeon areas
under core you'll also want to add a few
points into spell knowledge which allows
you to add more quick groups of spells
to your casting menu meaning you don't
have to constantly swap in new spells
during combat another great one once
you've had a broom is to expand the
range of revelio because you can scan
almost an entire location while in
flight and even pick up some resources
on the ground without getting off your
Brew
there are a few things that can make you
better at combat early in the game
especially while you're learning for
starters even though you can swap spells
to different button mappings it helps a
lot to keep your first two spells Akio
and Leviosa in the same spot to build
muscle memory each one will break a
different colored enemy Shield type and
speaking of Shield types if you go out
and explore the world early in the game
you'll run across enemies with red
shields before you have red spells to
break them such as incendio but you can
use disillusionment and invisibility
spell at any point even mid-combat which
will often cause enemies to drop their
Shields and go look for you opening them
up to attack you could also go invisible
the heel or just reposition it doesn't
always work but it often does finally
then this is a bit more of an exploit
but you can use high ground and Ledges
to full advantage Akio enemies near a
cliff then do a 180 and push them off
the ledge or just use high ground to
pull enemies one at a time later on you
can learn some pretty devastating attack
combos if you want to go the herbology
route a lot of plants are basically
grenades like the Mandrake which is a
flashbang grenade and chopping cabbages
similar are two bouncing grenades from
Borderlands if you're looking for
Mandrake seeds to grow yourself dogweed
and death cap just outside of Hog's meat
is your spot after you open up the room
of requirement again as mentioned in the
other shops it's at the edge of the
hogsmead map and easy to miss when
onboarding this game there's a ton of
info thrown at you and some critical
things are just easy to miss for example
the flute powder Network looks like you
can just walk off to it and use it but
it took me way too long to realize the
in-world representation of it is just
for show and you only use the network
from the Overworld map could have just
been me that missed that but do what you
will with it unfortunately if you want
to buy a broom right off the bat you
can't the store that sells these in
hogsmead is locked but I have no fear
you can unlock the doors to Flying
Freedom by progressing far enough in the
main story you're gonna be noticing a
theme here right after the flying intro
mission go to hogsmead's very own shop
and buy one they're a bit expensive so
remember that bit earlier where we
recommended you sell your gear
constantly do that when you finally get
to the room of requirement you'll
discover the main currency as moonstones
pick up a lot of them because that room
is huge and there's a lot of things you
can put in it in order to unlock new
things that you can put in that room
head on over to tomes and Scrolls and
hogsmead
the room of requirement is your little
home away from home you can customize
and decorate it to your heart's content
but it also serves an important function
in your adventure it's how you grow
herbs brew potions and identify gear
think almost like decoding engrams from
Destiny eventually you'll get a Quest
from Professor Weasley to check out the
room of requirement and she will walk
you through all the basics once the
tutorials are done you can start growing
plants and concocting concoctions the
reason we feel this is so important is
because wig and well potions are hard to
come by early on actually a lot of
things are hard to come by or very
expensive you don't grow them yourself
it's also worth mentioning that you can
conjure multiple herbalestations to grow
multiple plants at once just make sure
you purchase seed packets from the
magical deep and some fertilizer if you
want to increase your yield so that's
what you should know by about mid game
and we're still finding a lot more as we
go like you can pull out your broom
quickly if you're falling to keep
yourself alive let us know what fun
things you didn't know going into the
game and thanks for watching
Hogwarts Legacy is developed by
Avalanche software a subsidiary of
Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment the game has been
embroiled in controversy due to
transphobic remarks from Harry Potter
author J.K Rowling although she is not
personally involved with its development
she stands to profit from its success
for more on this please see this video's
description for a link to our in-depth
article on how Rowling's comments have
impacted the trans community in this
article you will also find links to
trans creators you can support as well
as Charities you can donate to